make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and in
this video I want to explain or have a
discussion about the character of Syd
Iraq from Marvel Comics and the reason
why is because Syd Iraq is is most of
you guys know is an exceedingly powerful
individual especially as the individual
that gives the juggernaut his you know
really operates as the juggernaut source
of power but this is gonna be an
interesting video because normally when
we do our character or team explanations
we start with their origin stories and
their first appearances and then we
basically sort of cover a lot of the
appearances they made over the years
highlighting the particular instances
where they crossed over with other teams
or how writers change them and different
things like that with Syd Iraq it's not
really the case originally he debuted
back in strange tales number 124 in 1964
but by name only and between 1964 in
1992 Syd Iraq appeared three times and
that was basically it
it wasn't until after 1992 but you
started getting a little more
involvement with his character and I
know it sounds counterintuitive given
his relationship to Cain Marko but we'll
talk about why that matters here in a
second but in the original story of
strange tales number 124 the invoking of
Syd Iraq only came by way of Marvel
basically showing the notion or showing
the idea that there were other things
out there besides what we had seen one
thing to keep in mind is at 1964 Marvel
was still relatively new they'd only
been around for a couple of years right
I mean the Fantastic Four spider-man
they really kind of blew the doors off
the idea of DC Comics having a
legitimate competitor right so Marvel
kind of came out guns blazing in the
early stories but Stephen strange and
and the Doctor Strange comics really
strange tales was designed to focus on
other things that were out there right
other things that were sort of
interesting but a little bit kooky and a
little bit strange there wasn't really
any kind of rule or any kind of
guidebook going on here magic was just
one of those things that existed out
there but if there was any one thing
that Stan Lee was aware of it was the
idea that the best way to build up the
Marvel mythos was to focus on everything
outside of the various superheroes right
to essentially do what DC was not doing
which was to say not to necessarily
focus on the individual heroes but to
focus on both the heroes and the mythos
surrounding those heroes and that's why
we ended up getting these these really
interesting stories we know in the early
days of Marvel where it wasn't just
about the the heroes and the villains
themselves it was how they got their
powers and then the whole mythos behind
the backside of how they got their
powers and all that kind of good stuff
and so following this named
more or less of the character of Syd
Iraq as an entity that exists out there
in Marvel Comics there wasn't really any
kind of reference to his character until
x-men issue number 12 the following year
in July of 1965 and when expedition
number 12 this coincided with the origin
of the juggernaut a released us seemed
juggernaut for the very first time now
it does give us the whole flashback to
the relationship between Cain Marko and
Charles Xavier the idea that Cain Marko
is the brother of Xavier him getting the
Crimson gem of cyttorak and different
things along those lines but the reality
is that there was an interview Stanley
had done where the question was asked
why is it that Syd Iraq doesn't really
seem to be involved all that often with
the juggernaut outside of the fact that
he's the source of power but you never
really see Syd Iraq and the response of
Stanley was that during this time period
when he was working on the x-men one the
idea was to build the x-men roster and
juggernaut was simply just one piece of
the puzzle right as far as the various
villains who were out there the
motivations for why these villains do
what they do but the idea behind
introducing Cain Marko was to sort of
bolster this is this kind of family
dynamic right to bring in this idea that
the x-men had to help their mentor fight
their mentors brother right and that's
what made things sort of interesting is
because it kind of shine a new light on
Charles Xavier his own history his own
origin story but the reality was a
Stanley never really saw that Iraq as a
being who needed to be in the forefront
and this lasted for quite some time
between 1965 and 1992 there were never
really any any instances where we saw
the character of Syd Iraq we knew bind
by virtue of the x-men stories of course
there being kind of a statue of his of
his character but we knew by virtue of
the x-men stories that sidorak existed
and cyttorak was the source of power for
juggernaut but you never saw anything
about it but the reason why I say 1992
and the reason why this is important is
because in Doctor Strange sorcerer
supreme issue number 44 in this same
year Roy Thomas gave us our first real
depiction of the character of CID Iraq
and the reason why this matters is
because sin Iraq as he's drawn here
doesn't look anything like the way he
would layer on down the line instead it
was kind of a rough draft it was kind of
this idea just sort of being thrown out
now I have not been able to locate an
interview from Roy Thomas where he
talked about invoking CID Iraq and and
drawing him depicting him or at least
having him drawn depict of different
things like that but given the nature of
Roy Thomas and the fact that he was sort
of the the next generation Stanley after
Stanley became editor-in-chief and the
fact that white Thomas had such a
significant hand
building out the mythos of so many
characters in Marvel and even had a huge
hand in the involvement of DC I would
kind of have to believe that while his
run on Doctor Strange sorcerer supreme
is by no means the most celebrated it
does kind of make sense in the sense
that he would look around and basically
come to the realization nobody did
anything with the character and so if
nothing else the big takeaway from from
this particular story was that it gave
us our first real appearance of the
first depiction of What's in Iraq could
look like but following this story in
the in Doctor Strange sorcerer supreme
number 44 from Roy Thomas what he did is
it set the stage for a bit of expansion
with a character of CID Iraq and we
wouldn't see a whole lot doing here what
we would end up finding is that in
September of 1996 an x-men Unlimited
issue number 12 that we would get the
first indication for why the Crimson Jim
exists on earth in the first place what
we ended up finding out here is that
there were a handful of monks who were
trying to find a way to essentially
harness the power of sin Iraq given us
extreme nature and then use it for their
own ends the result is that they ended
up summoning a darker aspect of Sid Iraq
his an inherent destructive nature which
laid waste to the various monks and
multiple villages around the area but
what this did is it led to a couple of
mystics named Gomorrah and tark who
managed to successfully subdue the
destructive entity of Sylt Iraq and so
as a desire really as is kind of a
punishment for the fact that he was
defeated Sid Iraq left his stone on
earth and essentially said like anybody
who touches this will become my avatar I
will always find a way to return this
paved the way and eventually led to Cain
Marko discovering the stone and then
becoming juggernaut in the first place
now this was essentially retconned in
1999 with the eighth day storyline now
the eight days storyline was initiated
by Kurt Busiek
and basically ran through a handful of
different comics you had Iron Man issue
number 21 you had Thor number 17 you had
Iron Man number 22
you had spider-man 11 and then you had
juggernaut issue number 1 but the idea
behind the eight days storyline was to
essentially take what had been done with
CID Iraq already in terms of his early
appearances in in the old strange tales
124 comic x-men issue number 12
Doctor Strange sorcerer supreme number
44 and the few appearances that we had
here and there consolidate it all and
then basically tell a wholly new story
and the way this played out is it
introduced something called the wager of
the octet sense which was a wager
between siddur aqua tomb vault art
baltic fur allah icon kraken and ragged
or and these a deities these demonic
beings were believed to have been
worshipped
on earth in the early days of humanity
and in fact there's a little bit of
indication here that they go all the way
back to the days of the Elder Gods but
regardless of the situation and they
ultimately came to the conclusion I came
to a kind of discussion over which one
of them was the most powerful and so
while they were unable to find out who
was the strongest ultimately due to the
fact they were each banished from the
planet Earth itself they each left one
artifact behind on earth under the idea
that when one of those artifacts was
discovered it would lead to the other
seven being picked up as well and the
humanity would be divided into eighths
and they would all go to war with one
another and whoever ended up winning
that war they would demonstrate that
their particular deity was more powerful
than the only others and so if
juggernaut was able to you know win the
war between the eighths of humanity and
he would demonstrate that essentially
that's it Iraq was the most powerful of
all the other entities that were out
there now of course the eighth day
juggernaut storyline didn't really come
to fruition in the way that it was
expected to insofar as humanity being
split into eighths and everybody going
to war and the end of all things and and
so on and so forth but what it did do is
it gave us a lot of origin with regards
to Sid Iraq and gave us a lot of
backstory that we didn't previously have
before now following this there wasn't
really a whole lot going on until we got
to 2005 2006 and 2007 with the launch of
new Excalibur now where new Excalibur
did feature sit Iraq and it really did
have a Ken Marcou coming into contact
with him again the significance of that
it was really confined more to the
juggernaut then desiderata the big
takeaway for City Rock's character here
is that it did give us kind of a
definitive explanation really basically
said that in the early days he was
worshipped by humanity he's somehow made
his way to earth after the banishment of
the original elder gods presumably due
to the fact that there were no real gods
standing in his way but that there isn't
really an explanation for why it was
that he was banished in the first place
why it was that he was removed he was
simply just removed from the landscape
and there wasn't really anything going
on there now again sin Iraq isn't really
seen or heard from much in malmo comics
until we get to the events of fear
itself and fear itself was probably the
single most significant story involving
sit Iraq really up to this modern day
and the reason why was because when it
came to the events of fear itself you
ended up seeing the brother of Odin Boo
nobody really knew about who deemed
himself as the rightful heir to Asgard
and in fact was the actual rightful heir
kind of awakening on earth and then
creating his own avatars more or less
and when a hammer was presented to Cain
Marko Cain Marko took it and so with sin
Iraq one of the things that was
established both in this story and
previous mentioned
is that where sit Iraq will lend his
power to other people really good
example as Jabbar not as well as dr.
strange who uses the crimson bands of
cyttorak ultimately he's a selfish god
and the idea is that those individuals
who become his avatar cannot use the
power of anybody else they have to
either find some way to bargain barter
or steal somebody else's abilities and
leave sit iraq service or they will stay
you know as is as is avatar essentially
for all time right because they'll
effectively be immortal and
indestructible and so the result of this
is that with sid iraq learning by virtue
of kitty pryde and magic and colossus
travelling to its crimson realm and
telling him that Jever not was wielding
a secondary source of power this led to
a transition from juggernaut from cain
marko being juggernaut to colossus now
the reason why this was done really
going into the Avengers vs. x-men story
that kind of piggybacked on that and and
you know with the Avengers vs. x-men
story actually seeing Colossus become
the juggernaut this was designed to
shake things up and the reason why was
because if you guys recall our various
discussions about Marvel Comics you know
from the early 2000s going into the post
heroic age so basically everything after
2010 that for that 10-year period
between 2000 and 2010 Joe Quesada had
look to essentially rework the entire
Marvel landscape he looked at the
entirety of the mutant population came
to the conclusion that the mutant
population was just too large and unruly
and wanted to convince them down and so
we got House of em he came to the
decision that that Peter Parker being
married aged him and took him away from
the idea of being eternally youthful and
so ultimately the marriage between Peter
Parker and Mary Jane Watson was
dissolved in spider-man one more day the
Avengers were broken up during Avengers
disassembled and then reformed into a
wholly new team during the New Avengers
storyline by Brian Michael Bendis this
all took place within the first four or
five years of Joe Quesada being
editor-in-chief the second four to five
years was storytelling it was designed
health exceedingly compelling stories
stories that were interesting that were
wild that were building on the changes
that casada and Bendis made in the early
days and then sort of going forward from
there and so when you look to the
character at least when fans and even
marvel look to the character of
juggernaut in a lot of ways juggernaut
was there and it was interesting to see
small little moments where cool things
happen you know where he fought the
Incredible Hulk as the horseman of war
for apocalypse and then ultimately ended
up managed to stop juggernaut deadness
tracks managed to actually push him back
where it was cool seeing small little
things like that the reality is that
khane Marco
gone about as far as he could in terms
of character development or at least as
far as any Marvel writer or even Marvel
themselves cared enough to do anything
with and so what this meant was that
there was a desire to shift things up
entirely
and so Colossus was transitioned away
from being a guy who had actually just
kind of been free-floating since his
return and Joss Whedon's astonishing
x-men run and moved into the role of
juggernaut as a guy who kind of had you
know double powers right he had his
inherit mutant abilities of osmium skin
and then in turn he also had the power
of juggernaut to amplify his abilities
now again with with Sid Iraq in this
instance there were more appearances
that he made during the events of
Avengers vs. x-men and he had made any
time before that combined and so what
you got were these these cool moments
where you would see Colossus try to
barter with Sid Iraq and try to find a
way to actually leave sid iraq service
consider i can turn would say no you're
my servant now you you you are my avatar
you cannot leave until i let you leave
what's also really notable and one of
the most important things that came out
of this in relation to sid arrives
howard was when colossus had the power
of the phoenix and when colossus used
both the power of the phoenix as well as
his his juggernaut abilities and even
his own mutant powers to try to face off
against against in iraq he was informed
that sit iraq as part of his own
dimension exists outside of the natural
order ie the Phoenix force holds no sway
in the crimson cosmos and so with that
being the case it kind of established
that in his own dimension sit iraq is
Nayan nipa 10 he's indestructible now
how that goes into something compared to
like the living tribunal or the one
above all that was never fully answered
but we can likely argue with those two
characters and even the beyonders and
beings who are just that astronomically
powerful that are so far beyond the
phoenix force in that capacity that it
doesn't matter whether these demon lords
are in their own dimensions or not they
can be destroyed right I mean that's
kind of the the nature of the beast when
it when it comes to their powers and so
the long and short of this is that CID
Iraq had more or less been presented as
is this my omnipotent and nearly
indestructible character but the issue
with this is that as cool as it was to
see Colossus become the juggernaut it
was never intended to last long term and
that's one of the things that you kind
of learn as you read comics for any real
measure of time you begin to see that as
things change they will ultimately go
back to normal right Jane Foster was
Thor for a time she went back to being
regular Jane Foster or at least now
she's Valkyrie but the title of Thor
ended up going back to Odin's son that
you had riri Williams who replaced Tony
Stark is Iron Man and then you had Tony
Stark coming back in
iron man again but these things always
go back to normal right which is why I
never really understood people
complaining about the fact that things
change unless unless they're new to
comics then that makes that makes
perfect sense but the idea here is that
Colossus ended up transitioning back to
becoming his normal self towards the end
of Avengers vs. x-men and sort of a
strange kind of situation right in the
sense that Illyana Rasputin his sister
could have could have stopped the the
entire process at any point in time and
even severed the connection between sin
Iraq and Colossus anytime she wanted to
the way it was written the ideas issue
one Colossus to understand how it felt
to experience damnation in the sense
that's what happened to Illyana Rasputin
when she was exceedingly young hence the
reason she became magic and it was
something that that Colossus could never
fully appreciate because it had never
happened to him this did create a kind
of rift between the two basically
separating brother and sister and
sitting in their own separate ways which
did allow for some pretty compelling
storytelling based on those two
individual characters but the long and
short of it was that coming out of
Avengers vs. x-men and the subsequent
stories had followed suit but you ended
up seeing Colossus losing the power of
the juggernaut and an intern Jabbar not
himself came Marco losing that power as
well meaning there was no sid iraq
avatar on earth now this ran up until
you ended up getting into the story of
the once and future juggernaut now this
story was written by craig Yost
and came out of his amazing x-men run
really with issues number 16 17 and 18
now this 2014 story was cool but one of
the things to understand is that Marvel
was leading up to Secret Wars right so
all these stories were basically being
written to their conclusions then we
were gonna go into Secret Wars we're
gonna get all kinds of tie-ins then
we're gonna go into the post Secret Wars
landscape right so the idea was to
basically say return everything to form
the way that is supposed to be you know
and we'll kind of see how these things
go and so what ended up happening is
Chris Yost ended up bringing in the
living monolith a living monolith is a
guy who can channel cosmic energies but
only under certain circumstances and
only if it's done properly for the long
and short is that as a living conductor
of energy that exists out there no
matter what that energy is being
provided with a crimson gem of cyttorak
allow the living monolith to become the
new juggernaut it was exceedingly
short-lived and it was designed to
basically have an instance where he was
going to be dispelled and have the gym
removed from him but with the living
monolith kind of failing to be an avatar
of city rock the way that Sid Roth
wanted him to be after looking at these
three characters looking at Colossus
looking at Cain Marko and looking at the
monolith ultimately city rock decided to
Reese
store Ken Marcou back to becoming the
juggernaut this of course ran through
secret Wars and then came out of secret
Wars which is how came Marco ended up
going back to having his his traditional
juggernaut role but again that's that's
really in when it comes to sit erect not
a whole lot to talk about here but I
mean he's one of these characters it
almost never appears in Marvel Comics
the overall appearances of cyttorak in
Marvel Comics
I think amounts to a total of like maybe
20 appearances and I would say probably
about 70% of those came out of Avengers
vs. x-men or it really came during fewer
itself and Avengers vs. x-men or when
his name was simply referenced he's a
guy who's there in Marvel but we almost
never ever ever see him or ever really
hear about him we just know he's there
he's the source of the juggernauts power
he's also the source of some of dr.
Strange's powers he's exceedingly
capable in his own realm and that's
basically it so with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to comics
explain make sure you guys are the sub
button to become part of the robb core
if you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later
purse
[Music]